this table we have two rows in one we
will have the class interval which will
be the price range of pens and in the
second we will have the frequency that
is the number of pens sold of each range
so these are the different class
intervals that are given the first range
is pens that cost between 10 and 20
rupees we can see that the upper limit
of one interval is equal to the lower
limit of the next interval making it
continuous as it's continuous the first
group would mean 10 rupees is less than
or equal to the price of the pen which
will be less than 20 rupees the low
limit is included but the upper limit is
not so in the second group 20 is
included along with all numbers less
than 30 but not equal to 30 in the
second row we have the number of pens
sold for each category 15 pens of this
category was sold 20 of this category
and so on until now we have seen
examples of bar graphs but never seen
bar graphs used to represent continuous
form of grouping let's see how we can do
that the first thing that we do is draw
the X and the y axis we draw the axis
and make equal intervals on each of them
then we label the axis since we want to
represent the quantity of each class
interval we have the pens sold in the y
axis and the price range of pens on the
x axis the steps are similar to the ones
we use to draw a bar graph now we have
to choose a suitable scale for the y
axis the number of pens sold range
between 5 and 30 a scale of 1 centimeter
equals to 5 pens on the y axis would be
perfect as we would need just 6
divisions we start writing the values on
the y-axis 5 10 15 and so on up to 30
and on the x axis we start writing the
price rain
of pens the first range is 10 to 20 then
20 to 30 and so on up to 50 to 60 that's
it now we just have to draw appropriate
bars for each class interval for the
range 10 to 20 the frequency is 15 so
based on the scale we draw a bar of
length 3 centimeters for a frequency of
20 we draw a bar of length 4 centimeters
and we continue the process till we
reach the last range this is called a
histogram bars used to represent
continuous class intervals remember 4
bar graphs we did not have intervals
here we just had plain simple categories
but here we have intervals on one axis
and quantity on the other what we did
here was simple we choose a scale and
draw bars for each continuous interval
but note that the intervals were
continuous 20 which is the upper limit
of the first interval is used as the
lower limit for the next interval but
what if the intervals are discontinuous
we will understand that in another video
you